so my name is Frank McKean and I work at
Intel and I have been working on this
particular project for the last mo8
years I guess and and I wanted to go
through at a high level how this works
and the mechanisms and if you have
additional questions I'm more than happy
to follow up with other things later on
but this is a overview of what this what
this particular technology does so I am
supposed to have legal disclaimers so
you everything I say here is disavowed
by Intel and no matter what you do no
computer can actually be perfectly
secure so and then there's something
else in the middle there that I'll let
you look at but now you do have to set
it up correctly to make an any item work
so we'll go through the problem
statement we'll take a look at the at
the attack surface area at a very high
level we will have more information
about that in a later presentation at
iske will then talk about the
programming environment how this fits in
today's environment we spend a lot of
time making sure that this fit into the
current environment such that you can
you can put this into an operating
system that's running today and make
sure that that's available and then
we'll talk a little bit about the access
control what did we do differently here
than what's done today in the processor
there's a couple of extra memory checks
that are done and we'll just go through
that at a very high level then we'll
talk about how you prove that you
actually have this and you're not really
being an emulator and how we can make
that work and then if we have time we'll
talk about some of the development tools
that we have done in the lab so
and let's go down so this is today's
environment where you have the
application and you have you have an
application with privilege code
underneath and you have the rings that
protect you
privileges from from the the privilege
code and then you go down into a another
ring and and you have your applications
and this is this was very good in the
80s when everybody was sort of on the
same team although we had separation
there wasn't an awful lot of work that
occurred to really get the bugs out
everybody worked together you bought
your code from vendors and and everybody
knew what the code was so you had a
design package in some sort of
accounting package and nobody was trying
to to take over and remove all the
things that you had that changed with
the internet to substantial extent
suddenly people downloaded things that
off the net they didn't really know what
it was it turned out to be malicious and
with the structure that's available
today in the Ring architecture once you
find a bug across that entire address
privilege space all 40 million lines of
OS code or whatever and you can affect
an attack on that then you've basically
caused yourself to lose control of that
privilege level and then of course once
you do that you've taken over the entire
privilege level you can now go into any
application and remove anything you want
you can substitute items and essentially
at this point in time you own the
Machine and everything that's in it and
so this is a fairly large problem as far
as we were concerned and I think we we
looked at this and said this whole ring
architecture is not sufficient in
today's environment at least that's the
the takeaway that we had rings need to
be augmented
so we we went on this project to augment
the Rings and we built these things
called enclaves but just to set the
stage again for an attack surface that
we have today an application in order to
maintain integrity protect its secrets
protect its integrity needs to rely on
all of that code to be running correctly
not be compromised and so you have
millions of lines of code that that
application depends on in order to
provide the mission so if your
application is a banking application and
any of those other three pieces of code
are compromised and it's not just the OS
we drew this as OS but it's really
anything that runs at rings there I'll
write the driver that you got when you
pulled some old piece of luck hardware
out of your drawer and you put it in it
suddenly that driver is in your trust
boundary so we wanted to do is make sure
that those kind of things and some of
the code like smm which is an Intel
system management mode that we don't
show here is not affect it cannot affect
the correct application the correct
execution the application so we built
these enclaves and essentially there's a
set of instructions that define a region
in the applications address space that's
that then is protected by the hardware
so you're the OS and VM can manage these
locations they can page them in and out
but they cannot access the data and they
cannot tamper with the data so we
provide integrity and confidentiality
and replay protection on those enclaves
so while those are executing the
application developer can can assume
that there is integrity in that
environment and will show some of the
ways the hardware does that protections
and this reduces the attack surface
substantially so so the other thing with
the way we did this there
were a lot of efforts to provide a
secure environment by having a separate
processor and so that would be a
separate processor with a smaller amount
of memory and you would have some sort
of interface and we changed the we
abandon that model we had that model
with txt but with this model what we've
done is have an environment which you
can now download into the normal
operating ad system address space you
can use the resources of the main OS and
provide that capability in your native
application and because of this it's
deployable over you can just download an
application it can have an enclave you
can put it on a lot you can do it
remotely you can have somebody that
decides you get a subscription service
they can download an enclave and and
bring it up and provide trust in that
environment so the programming model
this is the programming model before SGX
normally y OS whether it's Windows or
Linux or whatever is up in the upper
address space the code and data are down
at the lower end area of the address
space and this all exists in the user
process with an enclave we essentially
put that into the same address space and
it exists in this environment it's very
similar to a DLL and Windows and an Esso
file and in Linux so it sits there as a
separate set of libraries it behaves as
a self-contained unit and inside of
there there is code and data that is
owned by that Enclave and that code can
execute and and assume that it has
confidentiality and integrity and that
the data also is has confidentiality and
integrity and so the hardware is
protecting that area that Enclave area
and preventing accesses from things that
are outside of the Enclave space from
reading it
altering that area now we have
instructions to allow it to remove the
enclave and put it to memory but we also
maintain the integrity when we when that
happens we'll talk about those
instructions there are controlled entry
points we didn't want the we didn't want
to have to we didn't want someone to be
able to go into any place inside of a
enclave romp attacks are becoming very
popular now and that would be one very
big rap attack so what we did was we
have a controlled entry point so it
looks very much like an RPC type of
interface where you do an e enter and
you go into the Enclave at a particular
point and then software takes over and
you can't enter it anywhere else than
those particular entry points we have
multiple threading support you can build
as many threads as you want into an
enclave so it provides support for the
general-purpose threading environment
what needs to happen for each one of
those is we define a thread control
structure you put it in as you build the
Enclave it's registered as part of the
of the Enclave and then you can do an e
enter into each of those and we don't
have any limit on those as far as the
architecture goes if you have a certain
number of them and you have limited
memory on your machine you may decide
you want to limit them but there's
nothing in the architecture to do that
when you know I think when you when you
want to enter an enclave you have a
thread control structure that you have
there that you can use as an e enter
into that Enclave and inside the Enclave
you can have global data between threads
and outside you can have threads that
coincide but they can't necessarily send
data across that boundary between the
Enclave
I don't know if that answers your
question quite or not but essentially
this is very similar to the threatening
environment that they are today you can
have as many processors enter the
Enclave as there are Hardware processors
and you can define hundreds of these
threads and and still have you know some
of them are not used at any given time
so it's a very similar threading model
the other thing to know is that the
Enclave can reach out into the
application data and it can it can
retrieve data from out in that area and
bring it back in the application cannot
reach into the Enclave if an application
tries to read into the Enclave today's
implementations will return all ones you
don't get any information and some of
the future ones will probably return
ciphertext but essentially you get
nothing when you try to access that area
and if you try to write into the area we
just throw the right away now we still
may know just we still maintain all of
the page table protections so the
operating system hasn't been subverted
here The Enclave still must work inside
of the page tables in the security
environment that the that the OS has
produced in the environment well we're
thinking about that in a future
generation what what happens today
even without enclaves is when you write
to non-existent memory rather than cause
a crash of the machine or something or
an exception that comes back to
someplace where you've you know the
processor is long gone but somehow this
thing is rattling around and comes back
into the into the machine at the wrong
place because you've changed contexts in
i/o we just throw the right away so we
already had that mechanism in place and
so we just use that the same processor
is in the
get into each other they cannot now
architectural II we define this area as
an area for the enclave theoretically
the the architecture doesn't prevent
someone from defining an overlap between
them but the enclaves themselves will as
you put the pages in identify with one
or the other and you will get exceptions
and other bad behavior if you try to
overlap them but each Enclave is as
instantiated is a unique one and you
have to you instantiate it by starting
with this instruction will go into and
then you place pages in each time for
each Enclave so each one is is a unique
instantiation well there are another
questions
so this is the environment and I just
wanted to walk through some of these we
start at the very bottom the Akkar Duero
and what we've done in the hardware is
we've created a new memory semantics and
we refer to this as the Enclave page
cache and this this uncle
this memory access semantics is is now
doing extra checks over and above what
the hardware used to do when you made a
memory reference so in in the old
environment you went through the page
tables you've got a translation and if
everything worked out correctly you went
out to memory and you read the location
or you wrote the location in the in this
environment you do all of that and then
you go out and hardware will do some
additional checks and it will check to
make sure that the access is from
someone that's executing inside of that
Enclave and not anyone else and it will
check that the linear address that you
built the Enclave as is the same as the
one you're referencing so we protect
from some OS trying to remap the pages
underneath the application and it will
check also whether the application
wanted to have this be read or write
accessible so we have additional read
and write checks that the application
can have that the hardware will enforce
as you're building your Enclave and in
the first version that is somewhat
limited you have to put those out when
you build the Enclave on our spec we
have a second generation where you can
actually manipulate those and software
inside of the Enclave can can actually
make make changes there and do dynamic
memory allocation so so this area is
carved out in the first generation this
is carved out as a separate portion of
memory it's inside of a fixed area of
memory and and we and the hardware
declares this when you boot the machine
The Enclave page cache map is metadata
that's used to do all these check
so the hardware needed to go and check
somewhere and the memory that's used to
hold the metadata to perform these
checks we refer to as the enclave page
cache map this performance it's not all
that bad because you do it at a TLB miss
and so yes it is an extra reference in
the TLB filled pipeline but overall I
don't think that's a major we have
leather major or out performance issues
we'll get into later inside of the cache
so you can run if you if you do this and
you feel your TLB you can run a full
performance hopefully that will be more
obvious after I go through some of the
checks and if it's not let me know and
we'll wha go through that so the next
level up is the set of instructions that
are used to build the Enclave to page in
Page Enclave pages out of this limited
area and put them in regular memory and
- and to remove the pages so in the in
the privileged code environment and we
made this part of the privileged
environment because traditionally most
operating systems have managed resources
that's their major goal and we have
changed the paradigm that they can then
manage the data and change it but we
haven't taken away the ability for an OS
to manage the resources and so in this
environment we first start off building
an enclave by doing an e create
instruction and that declares an
instance of an enclave and it starts a
process we have a page that's put into
the Enclave page cache which is
declaring this is a particular Enclave
and and then as we fill in each of these
as we want to put the data and the code
into the Enclave we use the e add
instruction and that adds the page in
one at a time into the Enclave so you've
actually you just an she ate the Enclave
and then you put the pages in one at a
time by copying them in one thing to
note and I don't think it's called out
explicitly in these foils but as we do
this
there have been no secrets yet all of
this code and data is residing in main
memory when you build the Enclave so you
build an enclave there's no secret until
you instantiate it and lock it up and
then go ask somebody for a secret and
that's the the usage model we have yes
well so the next instruction I extend we
do a cryptographic hash of the data
we've loaded into the Enclave create
instruction yes how do you protect the
software the creation we don't we if you
mess it up the when we do this
cryptographic hash of everything it will
not measure it will not match what the
developer actually wanted to have built
so he should say you built a bad Enclave
I am NOT giving you the secret so it was
important to me to not have a by the way
not have secrets in this when you built
the Enclave because if you own the
machine you should have the right to
look at your code at least the beginning
to know what you have and so for that
reason we we leave this as unencrypted
data until such time as you actually
have something to put in for secret but
you modify the code and you change the
measurement so you can modify the code
but you cannot you cannot avoid
detection let me put it that yes so so
we assume that a developer building this
Enclave
will do so on a machine without
someone's having hacked it now if you
don't trust your tools you could have
have had been hacked in both cases which
case you will have the hack in both
places but if you do if you do this
correctly
on your machine without without any
malware on that machine you will be able
to build an enclave with a set of
measurements we will report that set of
measurements back to the person that's
provisioning secrets and this Enclave
should match that one and it's what
would the correct yes and it's
computationally infeasible to to
actually spoof that mechanism yes this
is gonna deploy for instance in the
context I don't know the details of that
particular microkernel we are working
with various OS vendors to make this for
them to develop support for this we also
have for shorter-term
built a set a driver that can actually
do all of these operations so a
privileged driver right now can do this
all this work so you can actually load
this without any kernel support directly
so yes the extend instruction will do a
cryptographic measurement as of that
page and and you we essentially have
this mechanism to accumulate a hash of
the Enclave as we're building it and
measuring it and so the developer needs
to do that on his machine and now he has
the gold standard he has a golden
measurement and when you build this on a
remote machine you use that as the entry
bar so if you don't have the right
measurement you don't get to get a
secret back and so people that modify it
can do so but that won't won't affect
the integrity well it infect the
integrity but will be detected after
we've built the Enclave we have an
instruction called Ian it and this is
where you can now declare the Enclave is
fully built
we locked the measurement down so you
can't manipulate the measurement any
more and up until this time you couldn't
enter the Enclave you couldn't build
half an enclave and then suddenly enter
it and now you've declared this to be
the whole enclave and you can now enter
it but now you're going to have to live
with the measurement that you just
locked down so if you did everything
correctly then the measurement should
reflect a correctly built Enclave and
everything is good and now you can go
out to someone and ask for secrets EEB
lock etrak you write back any load are
paging instructions and the goal for
enclave paging of this CPC is that we
can take a page out and put it into main
memory and bring it back in and it still
maintains the same properties of
security properties of confidentiality
and integrity as though it resided
inside of that area so we have metadata
that goes out when you do the you
encrypt the data you send it out you
have metadata that goes with it and we
keep a version around inside of the
enclave page cache to to make sure that
it's anchored in the hardware the epa
instruction is part of that versioning
for paging and and hopefully we can go
into that in a little more detail and
finally when you're all done with your
Enclave you can remove it and take all
the pages out of here and and therefore
free up for a new Enclave to come in
from the point of view of the
application environment the user level
process they would ask for an enclave to
be built by ring zero components or
privileged components and then once
that's done they would use the
instructions up there we enter to enter
the Enclave and start execution or exit
to leave the Enclave if an environment
such as most modern operating systems
you have exceptions and interrupts and
other external events and you leave the
Enclave we save all of the information
inside of the on clay
itself all the architectural state we
fill the registers with essentially the
reset values so it's the registers look
as though the part was just reset and we
go into the exception but then you need
to resume execution and the e resume
instruction is what's used to resume
execution of your Enclave when you
return and and then there are two other
instructions II get key any report and
those are security instructions used to
seal your data away based on an enclave
measurement or an enclave key that the
developer has generated and the report
is used to prove that this Enclave has
been built correctly and that it runs on
until pardon or yes some any questions
yes after we do the attestation slide so
I think that should explain most of that
well so this is a common system resource
and and traditionally operating systems
have managed common system resources and
so we we just felt that that was the
traditional way of doing this we wanted
this to fit into the current oh s
environment and and be something that
you can bring along and have one Enclave
and then you know grows over time so yes
so the e report is an instruction
hardware instruction that will do its
thing on that Enclave so it doesn't
really matter if you're in a it won't
the the VM won't have the key that's
ruisseau ciated with that particular
part so
there's some some set of numbers there
and not but it's it's big yes no that
was too hard made my head hurt we
decided for the first time we would just
do one there have been people sort of
dancing around that request but right
now we don't have that yes you could
have multiple instances of a non plane
that executes the same piece of code
they will each have their own set of
code and they will each be separate
instances and they cannot necessarily
you can't swap pages between them for
instance you know sure I can't share
code there is a request from several
people to have shared pages we're
thinking about that but that's not a
well yes right now we're still at this
stage where we're looking at other
things and that's not top of my list
some yes process specification Enclave
between local processes can be shared as
long as the address space is the same or
you should at least the enclave address
is the same yes you can add multiple
mappings well you can milk you can put
it into multiple spaces you cannot have
multiple mappings you have to have the
same linear address mapping or virtual
address mapping for the Enclave in both
is only going to run and ring three
there there are much better arguments
for well first of all most applications
are we looking at really don't need to
have ring zero support you know your
banking application and your
you know databases those things can run
it ring three so we also weren't your of
the entire we part of the goal here is
to make sure we do no harm to the
environment and this does change the
security equation for a platform
somewhat but by limiting this the
ability for malware for instance if it
gets in here is very it's very limited
right it's at ring three it cannot it
has to leave in order to go and take
over the platform it's a little bit of a
road bump for forensics but for the most
part you know it's pretty harmless so
there were a lot less issues to look at
so we we said for the first version we
really want to make sure that that this
is a positive impact on the platform as
we move forward I think there are people
asking for rings are privileged
components there and I'm not sure if the
ring is actually are the right way to
look at that ok any other questions ok
so I I have a cartoon here that explains
all of this in animation I did this for
training for some of our internal
customers and and so I've left it in
because it seems to be helpful for
people this is uh this is what we have
we have a virtual address space a
physical address space and whoops that
was not the right thing to do oh all
right wow that's scary
I remembered the slide number okay so
and essentially what we do is we we have
the e create it declares a range inside
of the virtual address space that's
going to be part of that Enclave we have
this Enclave page cache over here when
you booted the machine we declared this
what region of memory was going to have
these extra memory access semantics and
we have this
area of metadata that's going to be also
removed from the memory map as far as
the operating system is concerned and
hardware will use that to maintain and
check metadata and so as we move forward
the other thing to note is we have this
this what we call mr enclave
so mr. enclave is a is the measurement
register for the enclave itself this is
where we're keeping the running total of
the or hash of the Enclave
if anybody's done any work with TPM for
instance this is a very similar concept
we just keep this running hash too as we
move forward so we go and we're going to
take plaintext data we're going to move
it down we're going to use the e add
instruction copy it down put it into the
into the Enclave itself it'll be mapped
into that location by changing the PT ES
and all of that and the EP CMM entry
will show that this is now a ballad page
it has an enclave ID which is associated
with the particular Enclave and it has a
what we call the linear address which is
the virtual address intel has this
several layers of translation so i'm
sorry if i confuse you with that but
it's virtual address and we do that
several times we fill up the Enclave we
put it into memory and then after we've
done all that we'll do any extend and
we'll do do a measurement of these and
this will cause the measurement register
to be updated we'll do a measurement of
each of the pages one thing to note it's
not required that you measure the pages
if you have a heap area that you don't
care about you know you're going to
overwrite it and you're really sure you
would never put a bug in your Enclave
then you're welcome to not measure it
our library right now measures
everything so if you do this as part of
our library build you will simply
measure everything and then once all of
that is done we will declare that this
Enclave is executable and now you can go
in and execute in those pages
and you can enter into the Enclave you
can exit the Enclave you can finish what
you're doing so you can have this
Enclave up and enter and exit forever
till the movies over til you're done
with whatever metal record you had
whatever you want to do and then you do
an e remove remove all the pages and
they all become invalid in the e PCM and
therefore they disappear I'm not sure I
understood your question there is and
that's an interesting question hold that
thought for just talk about how we
protect from that I think it's the next
foil yes so we have access control and
there are two areas of access control
there's on the processor package where
we have control and we want to keep data
decrypted so we have to prevent accesses
by any non Enclave actor and there's
off-chip where we don't have any
protections and we want to protect from
that and we use encryption and and
replay protection when we have data that
leaves the chip so what we do for on
chip when we're going to check whether
we can access this page we have an
address request comes in and say a load
or something and we do the traditional
page table access and that will follow
the normal procedure if it's not mapped
the operating system would fault if it
is mapped then we have to do an extra
addressed extra set of checks so we
first check to see are we in Enclave
mode and is this an enclave access that
means it has to wear an enclave mode and
it has to be in that range of the
address where we declared the Enclave
would reside
and if it is those things is it well if
it's not those things then is it an
address inside of that Enclave page
cache area and if it's not an ad access
into that Enclave page cache area we
just allow the access to occur that's a
normal memory access we're not running
in an enclave mode nothing happened
there and this is this is basically a
hardware module running in the front of
the load pipeline if it is inside of
that we replace the address with what we
call a board page that's an internal
intel jargon for hey this is a reference
that we are disallowing so we will
return all ones for the read request so
applications get just junk and if it's a
right we will throw it away if it is an
enclave access then we again do a check
to see if it's inside of the Enclave
page cache and if it is inside then
we'll check to make sure that all those
references this reference meets all of
their criteria
yes yes you've done a enter instruction
you've entered the Enclave and you're
inside of that vert that linear address
that virtual address range that says
you're inside of the Enclave because we
have to if you are an Inc inside of the
Enclave and you'll see that in a minute
and we're outside of the EPC that's an
enclave referencing the external memory
and we have to do a separate check for
that we'll do that in a second that that
one in a second but in this case we do
the check if all the checks pass then
the memory access is allowed if the
checks are not allowed or don't pass
then we do signal fault in this case so
you get a in the first version you'll
get a general protection fault and in
future versions we will give a page
fault for this condition if the address
is not an EPC and it is an enclave
access which means somehow the operating
system or somebody has mapped this thing
into the wrong area
and we will also signal fault so this is
how we do all of the access controls
inside of the processor for all the
course so so everybody goes through this
new additional check inside of the
inside of the memory pipeline so did
that answer your question with
protections and whether we have to write
DRAM and all of that I was asking a
question in the context of the genome
operating system that has a recursive
ring model I say okay microkernel so I'm
turned out this can't help how this is
going to fit into that but let's
continue on I'm still okay I think the
question was what's he doing
we actually clean zeroed out what we do
we remove we do not say we do not zero
out the memory but once we do any remove
one of the checks in the C PCM is to
check that the vet page is valid and now
it's not valid anymore
after you remove it's no longer valid
somebody else you filled it with
something oh maybe not well in our case
it is because the only instructions that
you can actually use to set the valid
bit or require you to either write zeros
or to write some new Enclave yes we do
oh I did it again
I I am very sorry I keep hitting the
wrong buddy so let me okay
so outside of the Enclave we want to
protect the data and so as I mentioned
inside the data is unencrypted you can
run at full cache performance and we
have a security boundary here so if you
can take your chip apart you probably
and you can actually probe it while it's
running there are people that can do
that there are labs that have that
capability then you probably can bypass
this most people don't do this to their
chips and in fact in our in our company
we're not very good at this either
turns out we fail at this quite a bit
when we try to do it it does void the
warranty I'm not sure what they'll say
if you tried to bring it back at that
point I'm not even sure anybody's ever
tried again we I'm not sure that this is
a big secret people talk about how they
go about on actually doing these things
there are companies down here in Silicon
Valley that will do this for for money
so if you if you're a lawyer and you
want to sue somebody there are companies
that will help you with that so it's not
an impossible task it is harder as you
get down to very small geometries I will
I will say and that's one of the things
we're up against but nevertheless this
is our boundary and we've decided that
if you if you breach that then that's
past our our protections but when we
leave the chip we want to make sure that
that date of your credit card
information or whatever else you have in
there is protected as
it leaves the area so we have a memory
encryption engine that sits on the book
on the boundary here right at the memory
controller and as the data for for that
EPC area or EPC M area falls out into
main memory it will be encrypted and it
will be integrity protected and replay
protected and then put into main memory
and it turns out that not only is that
really good for for protection against
Hardware attacks it also protects
against a number of software attacks
that are at the corners of hardware
software so you cause a reset of the
part you don't want the all the
distribution all the protections to
disappear which they normally do well in
our case the key also disappears so all
that data is is essentially unreadable
so there's some very nice properties of
having an encryption engine right there
because I just keep trying until I find
one that matches now another key
this-this-this
encryption is a aes-128 it's you but
this is a 64 byte cache line coming in
and out here so it's multiple aes blocks
it's you know it's not just a word oh
yeah
if you try to write a word which is
possible in most microprocessors you
will have quite the event right you end
up going out getting the whole cache
line bringing it back writing them in
putting them back out that kind of thing
yes very critical but this key
management is actually just a random
number taken from our random number
generator when you reset the part inside
ever does anybody outside know with
this key yes No this key is randomly
generated at the time you power up we
put it in there when you reset the part
a new one is generated or read from the
random number generator and and you
start over we need to be in the clear or
encrypted with a different key not sure
what you mean by external this key is
only encrypting that memory there's no
external it has no external access
it's simply Hardware reads this value
when you when you reset the part and you
put it in there and hardware is the only
one that has access to that key we have
versions that are part of this the M EE
is very complicated it has a tree of
because we want to do this on a cache
line basis it's a very small block
relative to main memory so we end up
with a replay tree that requires quite a
bit of integrity protection it takes up
right now in the first version is like
25% of memories of that epc area will be
used we are working on getting that down
we have a couple of ideas there yes they
are wired by the cache line plus the
integrity data is larger than the cache
line yes the integrity data for that
block of epc is all allocated at boot
time so it disappears it's just out
there we it's consumed entirely and so
therefore the operating system doesn't
have to deal with it it's just gone yes
if you have the same block in two
different places there it will be
different and I'm not sure I remember
the exact algorithm that's used there
but you won't see the same thing
repeatedly and we have a version in
there so you never see the same one
if you write zeros every time you'll see
a different value there so yes I'm not
sure I understand your question yes the
replay the tree is sort of memory we
anchor it inside of the processor
package so we again go back
we have anchors in here of the of the
tree so that you you have to you can't
get at that in today's environment that
is true I think as we move on to very
large env data areas we're going to have
to rethink our interface and talk about
whether that is part of the trust
boundary and we do something locally on
that chip so we are looking at multi
package support so the first version
that we have available will be clients
only single package we've we've done a
lot of work on how to make this work on
multiple packages and I think that will
extend over to other packages other than
processor packages as we need it is
there another question what you're
asking is if someone else comes along
and overwrites that data well first of
all another core won't be able to do
that because we had that access control
mechanism we will prevent that from
occurring at least in the first
generation or two but if someone else
comes along that's attached to this
memory like you do port it and you said
oh I'm going to overwrite that then yes
it will cause this crash and it will be
painful because we will stop everything
and we will decide to reset the whole
part so it will be a very ugly event yes
errors and therefore the critics traffic
hash of my encrypted data memory is now
wrong it doesn't check and you're saying
that at that point your chip freaks yes
you're ignorant was bliss before now we
won't do this check in our current
implementation for clients that I
believe is is there is no error
correcting code but on parts that have
error correcting we plan to do is have
the have the ECC be checked and be
correct before you go for that fatal law
check yes but if you if you passed ECC
so somebody that's attacking this part
recalculates ECC says yeah this will go
in well yeah it will go in and and then
we will have an integrity mismatch and
and so then we will stop in order to do
this you have to do a hardware attack
you had to go and start putting data in
on the outside or have or somehow lower
the voltage on your DRAM or do something
that caused the DRAM not to faithfully
respond well most well it depends how
much you pay for your DRAM i guess most
intel when we design a static ram area i
think that's part of the normal testing
so that should not be an issue but yes
it is possible if you save $10 on your
dram that you didn't get that protection
i don't know
let's parkour the crackers more often
well that's that's I guess we'll see
whether that's the case so it is also
true that you had those errors before
you just didn't know them we're there so
I don't know whether you feel better
about that or not I guess I wanted to be
on the conservative side from a
cryptographic point of view so when you
make a guess and you actually fail you
that taught you something right it
reduced the space that of the numbers of
guesses you have to make anymore now in
the case of something that's like 2 to
the minus 128 chance it's not a very
large number but our cryptographers
decided that they would prefer to reef
or sever e1 to start over so when that
happens the key is changed and now your
guess is is like you started over you're
you're back at the full range of your
space so I guess we erred on the side of
security in that case something did not
have adjustments after people use it I
just think that's going to be part of
the course so where there are other
questions no not tonight
it is it is an impact we do have some
caching that that keeps that tree in in
some cases but in the worst case
scenario or you have to do this you
might walk three levels so you end up
with a memory bandwidth degradation that
could be an impact on performance that
is probably our biggest performance
impact
public for what the actually I'm not
sure we know we have our benchmarks have
been sort of back and forth it depends
on your cash size right it's it's all a
matter of what application you're
running how much of it's in the cash how
many times you're falling out of the
cash so the cash behaves identical to
any other application so in other
applications when you fall out of the
cash you see this we just see this at a
higher rate so your degradation is
faster in this case a cache miss might
be much more expensive it might hit in
the cache we have extra caches what I
mentioned was for the integrity so we
might hit those integrity and it's just
one reference we might also miss all
that and do three references to fill
that miss to prevent unnecessary cash
missing because well-behaved streams
don't necessarily work best with
standard statistical caching and so on
typically if you're a stream oriented
multimedia guy you end up having to do
workarounds unless the CPU understands
about stream process we don't have that
in this first generation I take it you
only do this for data that's in the
Enclave and for other data you did it up
to the encryption that's correct which
means you did it doesn't affect the
performance benchmarks or be judged by
performance where we're running
benchmarks inside of the Enclave to
understand the difference but but again
it depends on how much of it sits in the
cache and we have different processors
that have different cache sizes so you
know we have to it's not that I I just
don't think we have those numbers
well-defined you
and again part of this is to provide
protection from snooping and and things
from the main memory okay so that's the
that's the area that protects and
produces the the Enclave the walls
around the protection now once you have
that how do you prove to someone that
you have it and how do we go about that
so that will be the attestation and
sealing section so I'll start looking at
that and essentially as I mentioned the
Enclave is in the clear before you
instantiate it so you have you can have
sections of code and data they're
encrypted but there's no place to put
the secret for the encryption so yeah
not on a developer can download
encrypted data but he still got the keys
not sending it with it and you put those
into the Enclave and there's no way to
decrypt it you have to get the secrets
from someone outside you have to enable
this if you want this to be secure now
you could do that on your keyboard if
you feel that your machine is in such
high integrity state that there isn't
anything there and there are some
reasons you might do that before you
plug it into the internet for instance
after that you have to be able to
convince a third party that you really
do have Enclave hardware and how do we
go about doing that and we'll talk about
that so that's one of the major things
how do we show somebody that this is
really a machine that supports an
enclave and it's on it's a machine that
hasn't been taken apart we have limited
means to know whether it's been taken
apart or not well show that and then we
want to be able to after we do that to
an outside party we're only proving from
Intel's point of view from the chip that
this is really the hardware you may want
to store secrets in there and you may
want to have your own identities in
there for everybody that owns an enclave
and we just want a way to do that
without necessarily going through this
whole identification process so those
are the the things that were solving
here
so the service provider the person
that's that's distributed the Enclave
they need to be able to understand that
and they need to be able to vet that
this is a Intel CPU I've mentioned all
that and they need to be able to prove
that this Enclave can be has the
software running inside it that we
claimed this is the measurement register
and we need to know that the Enclave is
in the right execution environment and
that the sealing identity will be
that'll be used and the sealing identity
is something that that can that we'll
talk about a little bit it's essentially
who signed this Enclave and presented it
to the hardware to run and finally we
have the ability to understand whether
this processor has been patched we have
Micro code patch we've had it for many
years we can tell somebody remotely that
yes it is indeed been patched with the
latest security values so you can rest
assured that it meets this set of
criteria so basically when you generate
this cryptographic log we put the code
we put the data and all of the stack and
heap information that's been measured
and we also put the location of each of
the pages so part of this is when you
did this Yod we put the address of that
page as part of that hash and we put the
what we refer to as the security flags
this is the things like the
read/write/execute that are defined for
that e PCM and some other values that
are there and then we have this M R
Enclave this is the register we talked
about it's basically a 256 bit digest
and it is the TCB of the Enclave so the
software verifier needs to get this
information needs to get it securely and
be able to compare that against some
golden value to make sure that it can be
that he's comfortable with or she is
comfortable with that up
there is not you well hold that thought
just a second we have two types of
attestation we have local ACTU station
and we have remote attestation local at
the station is the ability to prove to
someone that you are indeed on that
platform locally and that you that you
have a particular measurement and what
IRRI port does is it will generate a
cryptographic report that will bind the
mr enclave of the target value to the
report key and then e Gehrke will
provide the report key to verify that
report and this is very very subtle and
I always forget it and I'll have to
remember it as we move through this but
the we have a cartoon in the next couple
of the pictures that'll help with that
and and so essentially what we do is we
have created a symmetric key that we use
asymmetrically for local attestation and
then once you do that we have the
ability for that local Enclave to be
provisioned with values that are
provided by an attestation that an
attestation server can then prove that
this is a a Intel Enclave
so we start off we have two enclaves and
we want them to prove to each other that
they're one to prove to the other that
that Enclave is there and that the
measurement value is indeed what it says
so we have those enclaves we have the
verify Enclave and it's going to send
its mr enclave its measurement value to
the reporting Enclave so I want a
measurement I want this Enclave to
validate that one so he sends his
measurement value over and then that
Enclave will do an e report with the mr
enclave and that will generate a
Mack and everything for that enclave
transfer that value from that Enclave to
that Enclave over an untrusted channel
is protected or unprotected when it
leaves the first time play it is
unprotected and the Mack is a message
authentication code yes or - yes okay
how are the keys no the keys yeah well
these keys are sort of being held
closely and by hardware via these
instructions
that's the subtlety I always have to
think about this because we allow these
values to be transferred the keys that
you're deriving inside the hardware to
generate these values are not available
to either Enclave okay so we then use
available hardware can check some of
these and we'll give you some results
back based on the key but you never yes
so we basically do all this we send that
whoops I think we went too far maybe it
skipped here we basically send this over
and and now the verifying Enclave can
actually obtain the report doesn't look
like it kind of I did this as an
animation and I took the animations and
I put them into PowerPoint and I think
that one kind of messed up essentially
you got it back over here and now the
the receiving Enclave even though it's
not here can verify this by obtaining
the report key its report key and
verifying this Mac based on the office
authenticity of the report
the Mac is part of the report and you
send that back over and then you can
identify you can verify the report key
by having checking this with your mr
enclave in it and as a result then so I
mean you really need to understand the
details of that up at a level that I
don't want to go into today but we can
come back essentially if you look at
that what will happen is this will come
back over the mr enclave is fed in as
part of the report as one of the
parameters into that instruction and
then you bring it back and you can
verify that Enclave using the Erie get
key instruction to to verify that that's
correct after we do that we want to take
this value so this is a what we've done
is we've said okay this Enclave over
here on the on the left side is is now
the one that has been has given its
information to this other Enclave and
we're now going to say well that Enclave
was something special that has a special
global attestation mechanism and in our
case we call this epidemis e ID is again
very similar to what is done by by the
TPM for their direct anonymous
attestation and and so we then send that
back over to the remote Enclave and this
value now is something that the remote
party can can actually do a check on
with an attestation server that intel
has provided and a private key and a
public key for a group and that's the
same sort of thing here so
no we went to this was this was the this
we went from the local attestation now
we're in the process of doing they're
the global one local is a symmetric key
and the remote is done with a asymmetric
key and it's a anonymous type of
environment so the remote party won't
know which machine it is that's the idea
then what they do know is that it's part
of this group and Intel will provide the
group members for that and there are all
sorts of cryptography about you can
decide whether Intel or somebody else
decides that this is a part that's bad
you can make some calculations and I can
never remember that crypto after I look
at it okay so after verifying this
report then this Enclave which we called
the quoting Enclave this is the global
quote that we're providing we'll sign
the report and we'll use the epital
convert it to something that's global
that can be used by the verifying party
and and then it will be sent over and
then the remote platform can verify this
quote with the epic part of the group
and and therefore at this point in time
the remote platform has now been should
be assured that this particular Enclave
that's here on this platform has been
instantiated inside an enclave on an
intel part that it hasn't been revoked
yes
no the AP ID is stored in this
particular Enclave we call their quoting
Enclave and it's provided by Intel
during a provisioning cycle that we
glossed over today but feel free to come
to our all-day talk and we'll go into
that shameless plug I know yes
well how does Intel decide it should be
revoked so the idea here is that this
remote platform this remote party the
relying party for this attestation can
go and query an Intel server and we say
oh you have to there's some crypto you
have to do because we revoke the part we
don't want the remote party to know
which part but you want them to know
it's been revoked so there's some
involved crypto that Ike yes yeah so
there is some method to do that the more
interesting thing is why would we ever
revoke one well if somebody brought
theirs in with in pieces like we had
mentioned before we probably could
revoke that part there are some cases
where you might you know if it's
published on the web and everybody said
hey I took this part apartment here are
the values we would know to revoke it
otherwise it's very nebulous and it's an
interesting security issue as to how you
decide as something's trusted more could
do that but this is for the remote party
so they're not going to buy this other
computer they just want to know not to
send there their secrets they're in our
best interest it certainly would be if
we could convince people but uh
yes there's this mechanism rely on the
algorithms business itself implemented
in the Enclave that's a secret at all
it's in an enclave which means that the
code itself is downloaded before it's
actually secured and it's open and by
the way we put it at an ISO standard for
episo-- you can look at the details
there yes only the keys are secret yes
we have keys that are particular to
every part so every part has unique keys
there are keys there that are keys that
Intel puts into the part and forgets and
there are keys that Intel puts in and
remembers and the ones we remember are
not part of the sealing infrastructure
they're used as part of this how do we
know which portion this is so we have
this quoting Enclave we need to be able
to tell which machine has that
particular key we use that and that's
that's what that uses for no uses are
fuses and they're done it manufacturing
that's it now that said we have some way
as I mentioned earlier we have this
security version number and we do do
calculations based on that so if we up
the replicate up the security version of
the part for a particular change and it
could be that we decide there's a bug in
that Conclave when we decide to up the
security version number we will have a
different set of keys derived
we wanted to make sure we didn't have to
recall the part of Fah there was a bug
and say some intel Enclave yes so if you
hear some up above some keys to a
specific machine up means that you can
somehow deny service machine so it
cannot procreate very well we don't know
which machines right we know the group
are you saying if we decided we wanted
to never provision this machine we could
say all of the Broadwell parts we don't
really know you know million go out
every day we don't really keep track of
where'd they go I mean yeah there's a
little paranoia I guess you could argue
but where I don't think we're that good
yes
no it's done this a matter of law of the
reset so we actually do some some
calculations that reset that create a
new set of keys based on the fuses and
it's best under security version number
one security reasons you use someone to
be up when you reset right when you set
everything goes away and we start on but
readings the upgraded security version
yes okay and then when you load a patch
back in because that's your base
hardware and when you load a patch in or
you load some software then we calculate
the security version at the right time
so then we can report that based on what
it is at that time but for instance if
we reset the part the quoting Enclave
isn't there and it won't be there for a
while so as far as the security version
for that part for that particular
Enclave it'll be awhile before we
actually get it done yes
well because I don't think we are going
to be successful being in the trust
for everyone go I think we are we are
forgetting those keys in this first
generation and then we are never going
to know them in future generations so so
the reason for that is just the
manufacturing process today and then at
that the some point we will just
generate those and they will be in the
part and we won't really know what they
are we just aren't there in this first
generation well it's that and I don't
think well it turns out if you go
through all the key distribution we
actually allow an owner of the platform
to inject 250 s 128 bits of entropy on
their own so we'll never know the
ceiling structure from the beginning
from from that anyway so so the whole
idea that you can give this part to
someone and they can take it apart and
know the values for that for that sealed
chain is very hard if we don't have that
owner what we call owner epic is is this
this 128 bits of entropy that anybody
can inject and it goes in and it's done
at the boot time and that is part of the
key calculation and then that is that is
going to be a unique value that nobody
knows this other base part we just we
try to forget that and and that's
something we were going to get better at
as we move forward yes what I asked you
about the software version how do you
protect the software version I'm not
sure I know exactly what you mean by how
you protect it well you said you
actually take the system back down to
the world artwork and then you reset
that will it will go back down to the
rock
while he will apply some security
version four depending on whether it's a
micro code patch we will supply if it's
a software patch we will do something a
little different how do we know yeah I'm
not sure what you mean we we use the
value that we retrieved from that patch
to calculate the keys it's an input into
that key calculation yes it's coming
from the well the version itself is
coming from the patch you load and it's
signed and it's encrypted yes security
version is the rest is a piece of salt
right yes exactly so it essentially is
one more thing that that's put into the
key derivation okay
you